we will now talk about how biologists
studied gene expression to analyze genes
implicated in the dioxin shift
let's make a simple experiment let's
measure
expression of three genes at seven
checkpoints
before and after the dioxin shift
and each element in the resulting three
by seven matrix
is the expression level of gene i at
checkpoint j
what is the expression level well one
gene in a genome may generate many
transcript while another may generate
few transcript expression level is the
relative
measurement of the number of transcripts
in the cell and we can visualize
this seven
mere expression vector as a plot on
seven point
and looking at this plot you can
immediately say
that the blue gene most likely has
nothing to do
with the dioxin shape because the
expression of this gene
doesn't change before and after the
dioxin shift
however the green gene most likely
is implicated in the diactic shape
because its expression increases
and the red gene also most likely
implicated in the dioxide tree because
its expression is decreasing instead of
analyzing expression levels directly
biologists
often prefer to study logarithm of
expression level and we will
follow this approach below this slide
you see expression level represented as
logarithm
we just need to remember that positive
expression levels
after transforming to logarithm
correspond to
increase in the expression of gene and
negative expression level after
transforming to logarithm corresponds
to decrease in the gene expression
and here's a little bit larger 10 by 7
gene expression matrix
and these tangents also below shown
as plots can we cluster
these genes into groups of genes with
similar behavior
each row in the gene expression vertex
corresponds to gene expression vector
and you can see the plot of this extreme
expression vector at the bottom
and clearly just look at this
picture at the bottom reveals three
types of behavior increasing expression
corresponding to green genes
flat corresponding to blue genes and red
corresponding to genes whose expression
is decreasing and in
fact in 1997 joseph de rizzi constructed
much larger gene expression matrix by
measuring gene expression for
6400 is genes nearly
all is genes before and after the dioxin
and the goal he tried to achieve by
using this gene expression
matrix was to partition all
his genes into cluster so that
genes in the same clusters have similar
behavior
and genes in different clusters have
different behavior
we can also represent genes as point in
multi-dimensional
space so that n times m gene expression
matrix
will turn into end points in
m-dimensional space
and our tangents will turn
into this 10 points and we clearly see
that blue points that whose expression
remain
flat clustered together is the same is
true for green points
and red points i am cheating here
because our points are actually points
in seven dimensional space we measure
gene expression at seven checkpoints
but here i show these points in
two-dimensional space
how have i done it in fact the
clustering problem
is much harder than it looks because
there is so-called
curse of dimensionality of studying
clustering of points in
multi-dimensional places
spaces so far we talked
about each gene expression
but we can also talk about expression
of genes implicated in cancer
in 1999 uri alone measured expression of
2 000 genes from 40
samples of colon tumors from tumor
cancer patients
and compared it with the gene expression
matrix constructed for the same 2000
genes
for healthy patients in this case the
result
is not one but two
2004 by 40 gene expression matrices
and the goal in this case is to find
genes
with significantly different expression
vectors
in tumor patients as compared to
healthy people and these genes if
found would represent potential cancer
biomarkers
that can be used for cancer diagnostics
so if we look at the healthy genes in
the healthy patient
in multi-dimensional space then for this
let's say 10 genes let's not don't
change the expression matrix we will see
a picture like this
but if we superimpose it with the
expression level for a cancer patient
and i represent them by different type
of circles
let's say for you see that for blue
genes
expression level in cancerous pensions
and in healthy patients are roughly the
same
but in green genes and in regions
they differ and thus potentially
green genes or regions represent
potential i emphasize potential cancer
primark
in fact there are already uh approaches
to cancer diagnostics such as monoprint
that test that is a test that evaluates
the
likelihood of breast cancer recurrence
based
on the expression level of just 70 genes
the question that we will be interested
in
how did scientists discover this
70 human genes implicated in breast
cancer
but to answer this question we need to
formulate clustering
as an optimization problem